hi welcome I know you're all very
concerned about global warming and I
know I don't watch the TV news and I
don't watch the image but this morning I
read the news and I discovered that they
found the solution did you know that the
red carpet last night was
air-conditioned and the red carpet is
outside I think we should just heat and
cool the planet right why not yeah I
have been working with Matthew for a
long time more than half his age and I
actually have known our speaker for
about half his age it's amazing I want
to I want to say a word with the alums
of Hillsdale College stand up again so I
can look at you because I want to
remember
so stay standing okay so
yeah and see there are two things you
need to notice what I mean is the older
ones are dumber than the younger ones
and the other is so Morel and Brittany
and who's that
Oh ray yeah yeah so that little nerd
right there is the general counsel in
the Department of Labor under a very
gray I mean I'd never thought I'd say
these words a very great Secretary of
Labor and Brittany and David work in the
White House and act like grown-ups
I don't know and and all of them I it's
good to see you all it you know it's
awesome I I thought some of them might
work out and then they did do you notice
there's a lot of emergencies now I don't
read The Drudge Report every day but I I
do read it sometimes and you know the
number of emergencies like there were
like 80 emergencies last night at the
Emmy Awards I mean Stephen Colbert
himself is an emergency but you know
everything is very critical
for a long time there weren't any
hurricanes and that was a sign of
climate climate change in imminent death
and now there's a bunch of and that's a
sign of climate change of imminent death
and the budgets had a balance or it's
not I mean it always is now right
everything is an emergency and
everything is a war and introducing our
speaker I want to mention why that's
dangerous in 1936 Winston Churchill
wrote a very great essay he actually
wrote a very great essay every year that
he lived and he died at age 90 but this
one is called what good's a constitution
and he he makes a point that's
everywhere in Churchill and that is
war is not good for freedom because when
you get in a war especially under modern
conditions you have to use everything
you've got you have to conscripted
Victor Hansen you know that is very
great scholar was on our campus last
three weeks and he gave a talk he's got
a new book out called coming out next
month called a second world wars and he
talked in this talk at the beginning of
it about the scale of the second world
war and it's just the most destructive
thing that ever happened and so you want
to avoid that Churchill spent his life
trying to avoid things like that and
ended up because nobody gets to
determine the course of events by
himself commanding and things like that
and then after he won his glory in the
Second World War he called it the
unnecessary war because if they'd just
done the right thing in advance that
wouldn't happened in 1936 Franklin
Roosevelt had declared war on the Great
Depression and Churchill's essay what
good's a constitution that's called says
that if you're going to have a liberal
society you can't be always at war and
especially you can't treat things in
domestic policy like they're the
equivalent of war because when you get
in a war you can conscripted if you can
script things then what's left of us and
our private lives you know the federal
government is making bathroom policy you
know I'd like to say only in public
institutions is backed off from that
some lately since the election but if
that's a matter of federal concern what
room is there for us to live our lives
and you know another thing how would we
know when there was a real emergency I
mean I counted more than 30 in the
Drudge Report this morning
emergency's how would you know when
there was a real one
what does Statesmen do well you know we
think that they're either principled we
think if they're principled their
statesmen and if they're not their
politicians those words are actually
synonyms and if you think about your own
life you'll soon discover that you don't
always do the principal thing and what
the principal thing is changes every day
it depends on the circumstances right is
it wrong to kill yeah
is it wrong to kill Hitler at the detail
of who that guy was it's a circumstance
but it changes everything right
statesmen are mostly adaptable and lord
help us today are they not adaptable on
the other hand are they principled - are
they capable of strategy are they
capable while they adapt every day of
pursuing some consistent line for a long
time our speaker grew up in Arkansas
we're not cousins
it's a slander against our state to say
that we are although it's a fact that
both he and I that married from outside
the state might be very far outside the
state in order to diversify the gene
pool it's a shocking thing to say but
it's true that compared to him I'm
actually kind of a city boy because he
comes from Dardanelle which is Coe
capital of yellow county yellow white
yellow whereas Pocahontas is six
thousand people good thirty percent
larger than Darnell and the sole capital
its dad was a farmer my dad was a
schoolteacher so you kind of fancy-pants
we were he went to Harvard
that's when I met him you know he was in
undergraduate school and I was already
an old man and I noticed about him right
away
he's a very purposeful human being he's
fun but he's serious the year didn't go
by was it 1997 I think is maybe when I
met him so it's 20 years ago 40 20 years
ago and he's 40 probably or something
like that now I don't think the years
gone by that I haven't heard from him
three or four times always about
something that matters he grew up
without any money his sister was
terribly like my sister
she's graduated the University I have
two sisters actually she's a graduate of
the University of Arkansas law school
and she told me first time I met and I
met him at his wedding
met her that she does his taxes and he
never had any money and that's because
he's impractical well he actually has
had two jobs that pay
well but he quit one of them to join the
army and he quit the other one to run
for Congress fiscally stupid
he asked my advice about joining the
army I said yeah you need to do that he
said most people say not I think he
mentioned Tom West who's in the audience
who's talking tomorrow and who wrote a
really great book lately that you should
read Tom West also told him he should do
it and he said why do you think I should
do it and I said well you're thinking
about trying to save the country and you
want to do something that's real because
everybody lies in politics right but
risk in your life is hard to lie about
that because you might get killed he
refused to be a lawyer in the army the
Jag jugg Advocate General Corps Harvard
Law degree of course they wanted that he
led troops in he was a ranger
he led troops in Iraq served in the old
guard
he led troops in Afghanistan and
reconstruction and counterinsurgency won
a Bronze Star comes back runs for
Congress wins runs for Senate pretty
quick if you come from Arkansas as I do
the prior family will be known to you
because they're Arkansas it used to be
kind of slavish but when I was growing
up because you know an old democratic
state and it's not a very big place it's
just great a very beautiful place very
very fine place you should go to
Arkansas
meet my cousins
proud of itself Arkansas us and we like
to return guys over and over and over
back to office so we had Wilbur Mills
and full bride whom I met when I was in
college and thought at the time he was a
great man
there's just no overestimating the
ignorance of a college student I ask all
of you alums to remember that and and so
then the prior family came in first
David Pryor governor you know
representative did everything and we
sort of have an ancestral thing going on
and so Mark Pryor who's an incredibly
Pleasant man and big popularity Democrat
and you know as you know geniuses in the
Senate go
he's a very pleasant man and Tom's gonna
run against him and he'd already beat a
former Miss Arkansas in a primary for
Congress so now I was beginning to
believe in him but I'll tell you the
real reason I believe in him what's
important right now I'll tell you three
things that matter a lot
North Korea is an agent of China is
threatening us with nuclear holocaust
that's important
read Winston Churchill about the power
of modern weapons and their ability to
overcome any chance for a liberal
society just remember like I can tell
you from my own line of work you can't
have college unless people can relax
everything is not a public policy issue
you've got to stop and read a book
you've got to think you've got to walk
slow to class if you want to you got to
take time over lunch if everything is an
engineering project and if you just
watch the TV news which I seldom watch
that's all it is it's converting every
aspect of life into an engineering
project but lord help us nuclear war and
that crappy place hosted probably by
that big that's serious all these
emergencies that they talk about on the
Drudge Report that's a real one here's
another one in a free country the people
get to govern so it matters what they're
like matters whether they want to be
free matters if they know how matters if
they've learned the right things I used
to not care so much about immigration
myself until the President of the United
States by executive order altered the
status of several million people and I
thought to myself one of the complaints
against the king of the Declaration of
Independence is that he expanded the
territory of Quebec which he could
control so that he could pick who his
constituents were in other words not the
people picking the government now the
government picking the people
and then finally a third you see in both
of these freedom liberalism living free
and right as human beings they hinge on
these first two things and the third one
is exactly the same I looked it up today
in the the Congress that ended last
January passed 358 laws two years right
that's about how many they passed every
two-year cycle for about a hundred years
but last calendar year alone
eighty-seven thousand pages were added
to the Federal Register where'd they
come from the answer is there's a whole
new government admitted invented in
America and it makes nearly all of our
laws and it enforces those laws too and
it adjudicates disputes that come from
those laws the whole constitutional
fabric is upset because of that I've
just named you the three things the Tom
cotton has spent the lion's share of his
job doing since he got elected to
Congress you think he doesn't have a
sense of strategy I introduced to you
the most promising young man Thomas
cotton
[Applause]
thank you
thank you all thank you so much that is
such a warm welcome and Larry thank you
very much for the kind introduction as
always after an introduction so splendid
even I am interested and what I will say
tonight now you know Larry has had the
occasion to introduce me on many
occasions and I'm always grateful for it
because he gives such fine remarks the
only complicating factor is the height
of these microphones fortunately we've
worked it out tonight
you know Hillsdale studies many great
statesman two of the greatest would be
Abraham Lincoln who was six four and
Winston Churchill who was five six is an
indication that the truly great men come
in all statures and something to which
we can all aspire thank you all
Hillsdale for having me back for my
second Hillsdale Constitution Day
celebration at first I thought this was
an encore performance but then Larry
Oren told me it was more of a shot at
redemption but whatever the case may be
it is always good to see so many old
friends and Patriots in a way not much
has changed since we gathered together
two years ago yesterday we celebrated
the two hundred and thirtieth
anniversary of the signing of our
Constitution
earlier this year Congress was seated
for the 115th time under that charter of
government and last year the American
people once again expressed their
judgement about our government through
regular elections but I think we all
know a lot more is changed in the last
two years that something more
fundamental is afoot for the first time
in all those elections our people chose
as president someone with no high
government experience
not a senator not a congressman not a
governor not a cabinet secretary not a
general it's worth reflecting on why
they did that I would suggest it's
because they've lost confidence in our
governing class of both parties in both
its competence and its intentions
government now takes nearly half of
every dollar our workers earn and bosses
us around in every aspect of life yet
can't even deliver basic service as well
our working class the Forgotten man to
use a phrase favored by Ronald Reagan
and FDR has seen it's wages stagnate
while the four richest counties in
America or all with inside the
Washington Beltway the kids of those
forgotten men are the ones who chiefly
fight our seemingly endless wars and
police our streets only to come in for
criticism too often from the very elite
who sleep under the blanket of security
they provide if you don't understand
this if last year's election came is the
complete shock to you then you truly
need to spend more time outside of
Washington DC
[Applause]
Donald Trump understood these things
though I should add hit him cause these
things his victory was more effect than
cause of our present discontents the
multiplying failures and arrogance of
our governing class are what created the
conditions for his victory immigration
is probably the best example of this
president Trump deviated from Republican
orthodoxy on several issues but
immigration was the defining issue in
which he broke from a bipartisan
conventional wisdom for years all
Democrats and many Republicans have
agreed on the outline of what's commonly
called comprehensive immigration reform
which is Washington code for amnesty
mass immigration and open borders in
perpetuity this approach was embodied
most recently in the so-called gang of
eight bill in 2013 it passed the Senate
but thankfully we killed it in the house
which I consider among my chief
accomplishments in Congress so far
two members of the so-called gang of
eight ran for my party's nomination for
president last year neither one a single
statewide primary yet Donald Trump
denounced the bill
and he won the nomination likewise
Hillary Clinton campaign not just for
mass immigration but also in a policy of
no deportations of anyone ever who's
illegally present in our country
she also accused her opponent of racism
and xenophobia yet Donald Trump beat her
by winning states that no Republican had
won since the 1980s clearly immigration
was an issue of signal importance in the
election and that's because it's more
than just another issue immigration
touches upon fundamental questions of
citizenship community and identity for
too long a bipartisan cosmopolitan elite
has minimized the concerns about these
things and put their own interests above
the national interest no one captured
the sensibility better than President
Obama when he famously called himself a
citizen of the world with that phrase he
revealed a deep misunderstanding of
citizenship after all citizen and City
share the same Greek root word and it's
classical meeting citizenship by
definition meant you belonged to a
particular political community yet many
of our elite share this sensibility they
believe that American citizenship real
actual citizenship is meaningless ought
not be foreclosed to anyone and ought
not be the basis for distinctions
between citizens and foreigners you
might say they think American
exceptionalism lies and not making
exceptions when it comes to citizenship
this globalist mindset is shall we say
foreign to most Americans and its
foreign to the American political
tradition take the Declaration of
Independence our cosmopolitan elites
love to cite its stirring passages about
the rights of mankind when they talk
about immigration refugees and so forth
they're not wrong to do so unlike any
other country America is an idea but it
is not only an idea America is a real
particular place with real borders and
real flesh-and-blood people and the
declaration tells us it was so from the
very beginning before those stirring
passages about unalienable rights and
nature's God in the very first sentence
in fact the founders say it has become
necessary for one people to dissolve the
political bands that tie them to another
one people one people not all people not
citizens of the world but one people
they're speaking of actual particular
people who made up actual colonies and
they frequently used the words we in us
throughout the Declaration to describe
that people furthermore on seven
different occasions the declaration
speaks of these colonies and these
states the founders were concerned about
their own circumstances they owed a duty
to their own people
who had sent them as representatives to
the Second Continental Congress in
Philadelphia they weren't trying to free
South America from Spanish or Portuguese
Dominion much as they might have opposed
that and perhaps most notably the
founders explain toward the end of the
Declaration that they had appealed not
only to key
George for redress but also to their
fellow British citizens yet those fellow
citizens had been deaf to the voice of
justice and Khan sanguinetti con sang
you entity that's pretty much the
opposite of being a citizen of the world
so while the declaration is of course a
universal document it's also a
particular document about one nation and
one people
the founders pledged their lives their
fortunes and their sacred honor to each
other in English right here in America
not in Esperanto to mankind in the
abstract the Constitution carries
forward this concept of American
citizenship it includes only one
reference to immigration where it
empowers Congress to establish a uniform
rule of naturalization it's worth
pondering a couple points there first
what's that word uniform doing the
Constitution only uses the word three
times when requiring uniform rules for
naturalization bankruptcies taxation
these are some of the things that could
most closely knit together our union or
blow it apart taxation by the central
government the system of credit upon
which the whole free inner sighs depends
and the meaning of citizenship on these
things
the founders insisted upon a single
uniform nationwide standard diverse
habits and laws are suitable for many
things in our continental Republic but
not for all things in particular we can
only have one people united by a common
understanding of citizenship
second that word naturalization implies
a citizenship process by which
foreigners can renounce their former
former allegiances and become citizens
of the United States they can cast off
what accident and force have thrust upon
them race class ethnicity and take on by
reflection and choice a new title
American that is a wonderful and
beautiful thing and one of which we are
all justly proud few Americans love our
land so much as the immigrants who've
escaped the yoke tyranny but our
cosmopolitan elites take it to an
extreme they think because anyone can
become an American we are morally
obligated to treat everyone like an
American if you don't you're
hard-hearted bigoted intolerant
xenophobic and so the only policies that
aren't inherently unamerican
are those that effectively erase our
borders and erase the distinction
between citizen and foreigner don't
erect barriers on the border give
sanctuary cities that pass spare illegal
immigrants from deportation allow
American businesses to import as much
cheap labor as they want anything less
is a betrayal of our ideals but that's
just not the case just because you can
become an American doesn't mean you are
an American and it certainly doesn't
mean that we have to treat you as an
American especially if you don't play by
our rules
after all in our unique brand of
nationalism which connects our people
through our ideas repudiating our law is
kind of like renouncing your blood ties
and the minar kacal lands of old and
what law is more fundamental to a
political community then who gets to
become a citizen
under what conditions and win while we
wish our fellow man well we only serve
our fellow citizens
it's our fellow citizens to whom we have
a duty and whom our government is
created to serve and among the highest
obligations we owe to each other is to
ensure that every working American can
lead a dignified life if you look across
our history I'd argue that's always been
the purpose of our immigration system to
create conditions in which normal
hardworking Americans can thrive look no
further in fact than what James Madison
said on the floor of the House of
Representatives in 1790 when the first
Congress was debating the very first
naturalization law he said it is no
doubt very desirable that we should hold
out as many inducements as possible for
the worthy part of mankind to come and
settle amongst us and throw their
fortunes into a common lot with ours
the worthy part not the entire world
Madison continued but why is this
desirable not merely to swell the
catalogue of our people no sir it is to
increase the wealth and strength of the
community to increase the wealth and
strength of the community that's quite a
statement quite a contrast to today's
elite consensus our immigration system
doesn't exist to serve the interest of
foreigners or wealthy Americans no our
immigration ought to benefit working
Americans and serve the national
interest that's the purpose of
immigration and that's the theme of the
story of American immigration although
when open borders enthusiasts tell that
story it sounds more like a fairy tale
the way they tell it America at first
was a land that accepted all comers
without conditions
but then periodically
the forces of nativism and bigotry would
rear their ugly head and restrict who
could come to the country they triumphed
for time with the Johnson Reid Act of
1924 but eventually but eventually these
forces of darkness were defeated by the
spirit of Emma Lazarus and the new
Colossus poem with the passage of the
Immigration and Nationality Act of 1965
which again open our shores and is still
the law governing our immigration system
today and everyone lived happily ever
after
well if I were to grade that account not
even as strictly as Larry or nor
Hillsdale professor I would give them an
F for history and an A in creative
writing because the history of
immigration and America is not one of
ever growing tides of huddled masses
from the pilgrims to today on the
contrary
throughout our history American
immigration has followed a surge and
paused pattern the first big wave was
the Irish and German immigrants in the
1840s and 1850s then immigration tapered
off during the Civil War the second big
wave was the central and southern
European immigrants in the late 19th and
early 20th centuries this wave ended
with the 1924 act and the years of lower
immigration that followed and now we're
in the longest wave yet the surge of
immigration from Latin America and East
and South Asia which is followed from
the 1965 act in this actual history not
the fairy tale history the 1924 act is
not an aberration but an ad in the
regular em and flow of immigration to
America after decades of unskilled mass
immigration that law responded by
controlling future immigration flows one
result of lower levels of immigration
was that it allowed those earlier
immigrants to assimilate learn new
skills and move up the economic ladder
creating the conditions for mass
affluence and the post-war era well
there's no denying that the story of
American immigration also has its uglier
chapters the Chinese Exclusion Act the
National Origins quota system imposed by
the 1924 Act the indifference to Jews in
the 1930s we ought to remember and learn
from this history one important lesson
though is this if the political class
had heated the concerns of working
Americans during the second wave the
1924 act likely would have passed
earlier and been less restriction
estándar lies not in addressing our
people's legitimate reasonable concerns
about immigration that danger lies in
our leaders ignoring those concerns and
slandering the people as bigots but then
we shouldn't be surprised when
politicians fail to understand fully the
implications of their actions take the
1965 act that law ended the National
Origins quota system and at the time was
minimized and its importance in fact
when President Johnson signed it into
law
he said the bill that we signed today is
not a revolutionary bill it does not
affect the lives of millions it will not
reshape the structure of our daily lives
or really add importantly to either our
wealth or our power how wrong he was the
economy we're living in today is in no
small part a result of the 1965 Act
because it opened the door to mass
immigration of unskilled and low-skilled
workers primarily through unlimited
family chain migration and that's not an
economy anyone should be satisfied with
today we have about a million immigrants
a year that's like adding the population
of Montana every single year or the
population of Arkansas every three years
but only one in 15 one in 15 of those
million-plus immigrants come here for
employment-based reasons the vast
majority of them come here simply
because they happen to be related to
someone already here that's why for
example we have more Somalia born
residents than Australia born residents
even though Australia is nearly twice
the size of Somalia and our Australians
are obviously better prepared as a
general matter to integrate and
assimilate into the American Way of life
in sum over 36 million immigrants or 94
percent of the total have come to
America over the last 50 years for
reasons having nothing to do with
employment and that's to say nothing of
the over 24 million illegal immigrants
who have come here as well put them
together and you have 60 million
immigrants legal and illegal who did not
come to this country because of a job
offer or because of their skills that's
like adding almost the entire population
of the United Kingdom and it also says
nothing of the millions of temporary
guest workers we import every year into
our country now unlike some open border
zealots I don't believe the law of
supply and demand is magically repealed
for the labor markets that means our
immigration system has been depressing
wages for people who work with their
hands and on their feet for people who
have to take a shower after they get off
work not before they go to work in fact
wages for Americans with a high school
degree have dropped by two percent since
the late 1970s and for those who didn't
finish high school they've dropped by a
staggering 17 percent and studies say
though emigration has a minimal effect
overall on the wages of Americans it has
a severe
negative effect on low-skilled workers
minorities and even recent immigrants
its automation to blame in part sure is
globalized trade partly to blame yes of
course but there's no denying that a
steady supply of cheap unskilled labor
has hurt working-class wages as well
Plus which among those three factors
immigration policy is the one that we
can control most easily for the benefit
of the American worker we've done the
opposite by allowing immigration to
consistently hurt our blue-collar
workers
trust me I know the response of open
borders enthusiasts I hear it all the
time they plead that we need a steady
supply of cheap unskilled labor because
there are quote jobs that no American
will do but that just isn't so there is
no job Americans won't do in fact
there's no industry in America in which
the majority of workers are not
natural-born Americans not landscapers
not construction workers not ski
instructors not lifeguards not resort
workers not childcare workers not a
single job that over educated elites
associate with immigrants because the
simple fact is at the wages decent and
the employer obeys the law Americans
will do any job and for tough dangerous
physically demanding jobs maybe working
folks do deserve a little bit of a raise
no American will do that job let me just
pause for a moment and confess how much
I detest that sentiment as I've said
it's ignorant of the economic facts
furthermore it's insulting condescending
and demeaning to our countrymen millions
of Americans make our hotel beds and
build our houses and clean our offices
imagine how they feel when they hear
some pampered elite say no American will
do their job and finally I must say that
cinnamon also carries more than a whiff
of the very prejudice of which they
accuse those concerned about the effects
of mass immigration but it's not only
the harmful impact on blue-collar
workers there's another problem
with our current system because we give
2/3 of our green cards to relatives of
people here there are huge backlogs in
the system which force highly talented
immigrants to wait in line for years
behind applicants whose only claim to
naturalization is a random family
connection to someone who happened to
get here years ago we therefore lose out
on the very best talent coming into our
country the ultra high-skilled
immigrants who can come to America stand
on their own two feet pay taxes and
through their entrepreneurial spirit and
innovation create more and higher paying
jobs for our citizens to put it simply
we have an immigration system that is
badly failing Madison's test of
increasing the wealth and strength of
the community it might work to the
advantage of a favored few perhaps but
not for the common good and especially
not the good of working-class Americans
and that's why I've introduced
legislation to fix our naturalization
system it's called the raise act
reforming American immigration for a
strong economy the raise act will
correct the flaws of the 1965 act by
reorienting our immigration system
towards foreigners who have the most to
contribute to our country it would
create a skills-based point system
similar to Canada's in Australia's
here's how it would work when people
apply to immigrate here they'd be given
an easy to calculate score on a scale of
0 to 100 based on their education age
job salary investment ability English
language skills and any extraordinary
achievements
then twice a year the US Citizenship and
Immigration Services would invite the
top scorers to complete their
applications and it would invite enough
high-scoring applicants to fill the
current 140,000 annual employment
employment based green card slots we'd
still admit spouses and unmarried minor
children of citizens and legal permanent
residents but we'd end the preferences
for most extended and adult family
members no more unlimited chain
migration
we also eliminate the so called
diversity Visa Lottery which hands out
green cards randomly without regard to
skills or family connections is plagued
by fraud and doesn't even promote
diversity since Europeans are the
fastest-growing beneficiaries
no offense penny we'd remove per country
caps on immigration too so that
high-skilled applicants aren't shut out
of the process simply because of their
country of origin and finally we'd cap
the number of refugees offered permanent
residency to 50,000 per year in line
with the recent average for the Bush era
and most of the Obama era and still
quite generous and it all up in our
annual immigration pool would be younger
higher skilled and ready to contribute
to our economy without using welfare as
more than half of immigrant households
do today no longer would we distribute
green cards essentially based on random
chance nor would we import millions of
unskilled workers to take jobs from
blue-collar Americans and undercut their
wages and over a 10-year period
our annual immigration levels would
decrease by half gradually returning to
historical norms and now given current
events this legislation is timely er
than ever
earlier this month President Trump
announced that he would wind down over
six months the unconstitutional deferred
action for childhood arrivals program
also known as daca President Obama
abused his authority with daca
purporting to give legal status to
illegal immigrants who arrived here as
children and who now are in their 20s
and 30s as we've seen the Constitution
reserves to Congress the power to make
uniform laws of naturalization even a
part-time left-wing law professor would
concede that the president lacks that
power and indeed President Obama
conceded it
because of President Obama's unlawful
action about 700,000 people are now in a
kind of legal limit limbo
president Trump did the right thing as a
matter of law by ending daca though as a
matter of policy he'd prefer its
beneficiaries don't face deportation
Democrats agree a lot of Republicans do
too so the question isn't so much about
deportation but rather if and what kind
of compromise Congress can strike and
here's where the raise act comes in we
can if we choose grant citizenship to
those illegal immigrants who came here
they're no fault of their own as kids
and who've otherwise been law-abiding
productive citizens but if we do it will
have the effect of legalizing through
chain migration their parents the very
people who created the problem by
bringing the kids here illegally some
like to say that children shouldn't pay
for the crimes of the parents but surely
parents can pay for the crimes of the
parents and that's to say nothing of
their siblings and spouses and then all
the second and third order chain
migration those people can create so
simply codifying daca without ending
chain migration would rapidly accelerate
the wave of unskilled immigrant labor
that's been depressing the wages of
working Americans an obvious compromise
then is to pair any attempt to codify
daca with reform of the green card
system to protect American workers a
standalone amnesty will not do nor will
an amnesty with vague promises of border
security which never seem to materialize
or get funded once the pressure is off
Congress but if we were to codify daca
along with the reforms and the Rays Act
we would protect working Americans from
the worst consequences of President
Obama's irresponsible decision
President Trump has said chain migration
must be ended in any legislative
compromise and he's highlighted the
raise act as a good starting point for
those negotiations I support that
approach and I'm committed to working
with my colleagues Democrats and
Republicans alike on a deal that
protects America's workers and citizens
but it won't be easy immigration has
emerged in recent years as a kind of
acid test for our leaders tests they've
mostly failed our cosmopolitan elite in
both parties has pursued a radical
immigration policy that's inconsistent
with our history and our political
traditions they've celebrated the
American idea yet undermine the actual
American people of the here and Mayall
they'd forgotten that the declaration
speaks of one people and the
constitution of We the People at the
same time they've enriched themselves
and improved their quality of life while
creating a new class of Forgotten men
it's not surprising then that the people
rebelled last year there's probably no
issue that calls more for an America
first approach than immigration after
all the guidepost of our immigration
policy should be putting Americans first
not foreigners and not a tiny elite our
immigration policy should serve the
wealth and strength of our people as
Madison said in that first Congress it
should not divide our nation and poverty
our workers and promote hyphenated
American ISM citizenship is the most
cherished thing our nation can bestow on
someone our governing classes ought to
treat it as something special we ought
to put the interests of our citizens
first and welcome those foreigners best
prepared to handle the duties of
citizenship
and contribute positively to our country
when we do our citizens will begin to
trust us once again thank you god bless
you and God bless the one people of the
United States
senator cotton was going to rush off but
he's going to take a few questions from
us this evening with his time there are
some microphones and I really can't see
you a few questions now that you know we
can't see you you don't have to be
worried that I didn't see you all
nodding your heads throughout my entire
speech to the extent I was going to rush
off it's because if you don't know we
have a two and a half year old and a 9
month old at home who need baths and
diaper changes when I mentioned this to
some of the more senior and seasoned
members of the Senate like Mitch
McConnell or Orrin Hatch or Chuck
Grassley they stare at me and say that's
not the way we did it in my age yes sir
is a possible solution to the daca issue
the beneficiaries of daca and perhaps in
other areas as well that they become
permanent residents but not citizens
with the right to vote so some
Republicans suggest that as a source of
compromise I would prefer to see if
we're going to give legal status to
these people in their 20s and 30s who
came here as kids through no fault of
their own that they also have the
opportunity to become American citizens
at no time in our country's history am i
aware of a class of people who were
permitted to live here permanently and
lawfully without becoming American
citizens so I think it would be
inconsistent to take that step with our
political tradition I also think it
would be politically unwise because the
day that you pass a law just like that
and that is one of the compromises the
Democrats dib to the Republicans is the
day that the Democrats are on the west
front of the Capitol denouncing the new
separate-but-equal in the new Jim Crow
that's a simple fact so what we should
do is if we're going to have a
compromise make sure that we mitigate
the negative side effects of codifying
daca for those 700,000 recipients of
that status the first is ending chain
migration so you don't have the largest
amnesty in American history through
their extended families and the second
is trying to
reduce the incentives that you create
for more illegal immigration I mean
think about it if you lived in El
Salvador the most dangerous place on
earth
more so than Syria more so than Iraq
more so than Afghanistan and the
American people just gave citizenship to
people who were brought here illegally
as children what would you do with your
three-year-old child with your two and a
half year old son and your nine month
old son you'd probably risk your life
and their lives to make that harrowing
journey to the United States that's bad
for us it's bad for them it is an
immoral and dangerous policy which
simply says if you survive the trip you
can stay so we have to take additional
measures to ensure that we decrease the
incentives for illegal immigration that
doesn't have to be the wall the wall is
mostly a funding matter I support the
President on that but Congress gives you
every year sometimes every three months
a chance to have that debate but things
like expanding the use of employment
verification systems so you not only
counteract illegal immigration on our
border but also through people who
lawfully enter on a visa but overstay
that visa perhaps more agents for
Customs and Border Patrol and
immigrations and custom enforcement more
judges for our immigration courts so
they can clear out the backlog of all
the countries or all the people who are
waiting for deportation maybe finally
taking some actions against the
countries who refuse to accept their
citizens back on their land
even though we want to deport them yet
they still live under the blanket of
security we provide them and receive
foreign aid from our government those
are a few contours of things we could
debate about but I think from our
standpoint both to be consistent with
our political traditions and also
politically prudent it would probably
unwise to create a new class of people
who can live here permanently and
lawfully but without the opportunity to
become citizens at some point in the
future
santé : Sebastian Gorka thank you for a
very forceful little clearly heartfelt
presentation my time in the White House
and since then I've constantly
emphasized the point you made that it is
very significant that a man who has
never held public office or had a flag
officer rank is now the president of
United States can you tell us how many
of your fellow GOP colleagues understand
the significance of what happened on
November the 8th not as many as they
should and and I make this point
sometimes that you know even if you
didn't support Donald Trump and the
primary even if you didn't support him
in the general election he won and you
should reflect on the reasons that he
won as I said I think he's more effect
than cause of our present discontent he
saw a lot of things about our governing
class that most people in Washington
didn't see immigration was the most
fundamental of those issues because it
was a bipartisan break that he made but
on issues like trade law and order
criminal justice he saw things that too
many people in Washington didn't see yet
on Capitol Hill
sometimes Republicans act as if the
election didn't happen as if we don't
resurrect the gang of eight legislation
from 2013 we're going to condemn
ourselves to a permanent minority status
and I asked him like did you see what
happened in the election last year
Donald Trump won he didn't lose he got
more Hispanic votes they may romney did
in 2012 after saying some politically
incorrect things about people of latin
american origin you should think about
what he appealed to among american
voters of all races of all ages of both
sexes all parties to many people in
washington though are still trying to
adjust to what happened last year and
that's one of the reasons i think you
see some of the ongoing problems we have
in the congress alright time for maybe
one more hi thank you for being here you
mentioned the wall earlier later in your
speech but thank you for mentioning it
why does it continue to be pushed to the
backburner
you said it's every three years why why
isn't the discussion now about the wall
walls work no it's every every three
months so the wall is primarily a matter
of government funding not government
policy that means that every year when
we passed the annual funding bills
that's an opportunity to try to obtain
more funding for the wall now the
president has said they have funding for
some of the preliminary steps they made
whether it's renovating current barriers
like we have in California soliciting
design proposals or so forth just like
Rome a wall will not be built in a day
but you are very right that walls work
physical barriers work they worked in
California to stop the flows of illegal
immigration over that border they worked
in Hungary they worked in Israel walls
work to say that walls don't work is to
say that it's like saying fire or the
wheel doesn't work there's a reason why
we have a fence around the White House
Barack Obama never took his fence down
when he lived there when he kept saying
walls didn't work of course they were
you may oppose it you may think it's you
know morally displeasing or unaesthetic
but they work and I would say they are
very needed especially given some of the
security threats we are apt to face not
just from Mexico but from Latin America
in the coming years so the president is
right that we need a wall we need a
strong double-sided barrier that stops
illegal immigrants and crime and drugs
from crossing our border now if it's not
part of any document it won't be there's
gonna be another government funding
debate in December if they're already
happening right now it will conclude by
December 8th and that'll happen every
single year and I think the president is
fully committed to making sure that we
take the steps we need to secure our
southern border with a physical barrier
thank you all very much
I'll get home in time for the late-night
wake up of my youngest son thank you